the movie opens up as a middle-aged
woman named stephanie records herself
live on instagram she seems to be making
some kind of announcement and her
followers are excited to hear it
following this we are taken to the past
where stephanie is with her family and
friends inside a bowling club it is her
14th birthday and she narrates about how
moving to the u.s from australia was a
hard step for her being a foreign kid
everybody making fun of her she further
mentions that the ultimate goal of her
school life is to be popular as steph is
having fun with her friends she spots a
popular guy named blaine and immediately
gets hypnotized by him unfortunately he
is with his arrogant and egocentric
girlfriend tiffany despite this steph
gathers up some courage and approaches
the duo to ask them if they'd like to
join her birthday party sadly tiffany
makes fun of the party and takes blane
away frustrated with her life steph vows
to herself that she will become popular
at any cost and with years passing by
she works hard and becomes the leader of
the cheerleading group now she has a lot
of friends and has even hooked up with
her dream boy blaine in the next scene a
17 year old staff is preparing to go to
school and her best friend seth is
waiting for her downstairs turns out
that seth has a major crush on her but
he is too afraid to let his feelings out
before leaving steph's father jim hands
her a dress that her mother left for her
before passing away steph becomes
emotional and decides to wear it at the
prom happening in a few days on the way
to school steph comes across the home of
her idol diana rousseau and stops diana
was the prom queen of 95 and has been
living the perfect life beautiful body a
great house and a handsome husband steph
envies their life but is hopeful that
one day she and blaine can replicate it
after this she discusses with seth about
the upcoming prom and how much she
despises tiffany steph is quite
confident of being crowned the prom
queen and she has already arranged an
after prom party at her friend martha's
lake house in class steph finds out that
tiffany is also holding an after prom
party and gets jealous she immediately
confronts her in the restroom and the
two start arguing later the cheer group
bulldog
is getting ready for a practice session
in front of the entire school martha
being the equipment manager tries to
instruct the group on how to do well but
tiffany interrupts and bullies her this
enrages steph and she makes a mockery of
tiffany in front of the entire group
after everyone is gone a distraught
tiffany starts plotting something with
two of her friends soon the performance
begins and the group starts dancing
gracefully despite having their
differences tiffany and steph also give
their best and the audience seems to be
loving it near the end of the
performance steph leaps into the air for
her signature jump but unfortunately the
two girls push the boy who is supposed
to catch staff as a result she drops to
the floor and the screen fades to black
the movie then cuts to 20 years in the
future where steph suddenly wakes up
from her coma in the hospital she
notices several birthday presents near
her bed some of which are for a 37 year
old confused steph leaves her room and
ventures outside she approaches the
receptionist and asks her if there's
been a mix-up in her room right then
steph sees her transformed self in the
mirror and passes out leaving everyone
stunned later the doctor reveals to
steph that it is 2022 and she has been
in a coma for nearly 20 years meanwhile
jim and martha arrive at the place they
are overjoyed to see stuff back after 20
long years as jim is hugging his
daughter the doctor suggests he take it
slow as martha is still a 17 year old
mentally despite having the body of a 37
year old following this jim and martha
decide to take steph home on the way
back steph is taken aback to see a
smartphone which she mistakes for a
small tv she's not wrong she is also
shocked that some words that were common
in the past are too offensive to use
these days martha then reveals to her
that she is the principal of harding
high school the same school they both
attended just then steph spots a
grown-up blaine but surprisingly he is
at diane rousseau's house confused steph
asks her dad to stop the car but when he
doesn't comply she jumps out of it she
then goes up to the house but gets
shocked to see tiffany come out of it
tiffany expresses her delight and having
her friend back and also reveals that
she got married to blaine and her
parents bought this house for her as a
gift despite this steph still wants to
meet blaine but tiffany makes an excuse
and tells her to come back later an
annoyed steph reaches home but as soon
as she enters her room she gets
emotional to find out that jim has
preserved all of her belongings at night
someone knocks on the door but when
steph goes out she finds no one around
instead she finds a book which was sent
by her best friend seth she opens it and
finds several pictures of her at school
this makes her emotional and she
remembers her late mother who always
believed that she could do something big
with this she gets renewed motivation
and vows to herself that she will again
become popular the next morning steph
approaches martha as she is about to
leave for school she then reveals her
desire to join harding high school and
complete her studies martha tries her
best to convince her friend that she is
too old for it but the latter is adamant
in her decision finally with no choice
left martha agrees to let steph join
school again in the next scene steph
gets ready for her first day at school
after 20 years and leaves the house full
of confidence however on reaching it she
finds that the place has changed a lot
everything has become student-friendly
so that it doesn't offend anyone for
instance the prom winners list is
replaced by a piece of art because it
sends the wrong message right then steph
bumps into seth and the two are
delighted to see one another turns out
that seth is the librarian in the same
school after a bit of small talk the two
head their separate ways but not before
promising to catch up soon following
this steph meets up with martha in her
office and requests to join the bulldogs
cheer group again she mentions that she
wants to join the group so she can
become popular and ultimately win the
prize of prom queen sadly martha
mentions that the school doesn't have a
prom queen anymore hearing this steph
becomes sad but she is not yet ready to
give up on her dreams so quickly she
heads to the cafeteria with a petition
paper to bring prom queen back there she
meets three students janet yaz and neil
who are immediately impressed by her
persona steph hands them the petition
and the three gladly sign it however she
quickly learns that no one else will
sign it unless the most popular kid in
school brie loves does it first turns
out that brie is a social media
influencer who has more than 3 million
followers on instagram she has a popular
boyfriend lance and the two are regarded
as untouchables in school this is
unrealistic no one names their kid lance
in 2022. soon brie approaches the group
and when steph asks her to sign the
petition she denies claiming that she is
paper-free before leaving she mentions
to steph that she's tiffany's daughter
which surprises steph later steph heads
to the playing ground and finds out that
martha is the cheer group coach janet
and yaz are also in the group but they
are performing some sort of cringe
routine which makes steph laugh turns
out that the school banned all forms of
sexy dancing as it was offensive to some
students frustrated steph heads to the
library and meets up with seth there she
learns about the wonders of instagram
and how one can become popular through
it hence she goes home and pleads with
her dad to get her a phone but
surprisingly her dad has already bought
one for her this delights steph and she
spends the whole night live streaming
herself now she has only one goal in
mind to gain more instagram followers
this is even sadder than the 20-year
coma the next day steph and some other
students are group studying at janet's
house however the only thing that is on
her mind is being crowned the prom queen
hence she gives her friends an
inspirational speech on how to become
popular and even makes them dance to her
favorite moves in the next scene
principal martha is hosting a ceremony
where all the students along with their
parents have gathered soon she hands
over the podium to tiffany who turns out
to be the head of the pta association of
harding high school even here she shows
her selfish nature by announcing that
the prom tickets will cost a massive 93
dollars now it's time for the dance
performance of the bulldogs led by steph
they come on stage and start performing
a boring routine which is based on the
usual equality bs however they quickly
change their outfits and start dancing
in a sexy manner this surprises all the
parents in the audience including
tiffany but blaine seems to be impressed
by it blaine is a creep the next morning
when steph wakes up she finds out that
her dancing video has gone viral and now
she has a lot of followers on instagram
she heads to school with a different
swag and everyone seems to like her now
however martha accuses her of ruining
the ceremony with her erotic dance moves
in her defense steph says that she is
trying to make the school more fun she
claims that living in the coma was much
more fun than going to martha's school
elsewhere an enraged tiffany approaches
her daughter and orders her to reinstate
the prom queen furthermore she wants
brie to take part and beat steph for the
crown bree denies swiftly claiming that
she isn't interested but when tiffany
threatens to ground her she has no
choice but to agree meanwhile steph and
seth are out on a date where the former
expresses her desire to become the prom
queen she becomes emotional and mentions
how her mother always believed in her
and this is why the goal is extra
important in her life hearing this seth
decides to be her prom partner and
support her the next day martha
announces that on bree's request the
school is reinstating the election for
king and queen at prom this delights
steph and her group and they start
planning for the event however steph
soon finds out that brie will be pitted
against her for the crown in class all
the students except steph get an
invitation from tiffany for an after
prom party frustrated steph decides to
announce her own after prom party she
heads home and frantically searches her
closet for something after a while she
finds the keys to martha's lake house
goes live on instagram and announces
she's hosting a free party after she
wins the prom in the next scene the prom
night has finally arrived and seth is
waiting for steph to get ready there he
has an awkward conversation with jim who
suggests he carry protection just then
steph arrives wearing her late mother's
dress steph is stunned by her beauty and
they click a lot of pictures before
leaving at the prom steph spots tiffany
at the voting booth and starts taunting
her she even votes for brie saying that
she's confident that she'll win after
this she goes outside to start a live
stream but bumps into blaine blaine
starts seducing her but as steph is
trying to push him away seth catches
them in action he walks out of the place
disappointed despite steph trying to
stop him in the meantime the prom
results are announced lance is crowned
the prom king as expected however bree
withdraws from the election at the last
moment leaving steph the eventual winner
everyone cheers for her in tandem
including brie but tiffany is left
speechless soon lance and steph put on
their crowns and perform a wonderful
dance impressing everyone there after
the event the students head to steph's
after prom party at the lake house
everyone enjoys themselves in the
wildest way possible meanwhile an
envious tiffany calls the police as she
is still furious at steph for ruining
her plans in no time the cops arrive
forcing the students to flee from the
place martha also arrives and berates
staff for putting the school's image in
jeopardy she then storms away from the
place along with seth leaving steph
alone and sad with no one to drop her at
home steph takes a lift but is shocked
to find out that diana rousseau is the
driver turns out that diana lost her
husband wealth and fame once she turned
30. she mentions her regrets for being
obsessed with popularity when she could
have studied hard and become something
hearing this steph realizes her mistakes
and when she reaches home she rips out
all of her posters the next morning a
distraught steph heads to the kitchen
but jim cheers her up by talking about
the importance of family and friends the
speech convinces steph to apologize to
martha and seth and this is when she
goes live as shown at the start of the
movie she gives a heartfelt apology
revealing that seth and martha were the
only ones who supported her when she was
new in the country after the stream is
over tiffany surprisingly arrives
outside and issues an apology of her own
for all the troubles she has given to
steph although unusual steph accepts the
apology and the two reconcile the next
day the school is hosting the graduation
ceremony all the students are called
upon the stage and when it's steph's
turn she expresses her gratitude for
having a friend like martha following
this the entire dance crew including
tiffany martha seth and even blaine
start dancing to steph's favorite moves
this surprises steph but she can't help
but join the group they all start
twerking viciously at last she performs
her famous jump and this time she lands
it perfectly the movie ends as steph and
seth finally make out and express their
love subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching